[Music]
i heard you guys talking about mike
tyson earlier you guys mike tyson fans
[ __ ] yeah i love him who isn't i didn't
know how messed up he was i watched the
documentary
in what way uh
like i knew he bit a dude's ear off and
like all right whatever but like i got a
dude's ear yeah dude a legends you're
off yeah okay
yeah but then like i didn't know barb
was it barbara walters have you seen
that interview where his wife just
interrupts the interview no no see mike
tyson's like on 2020 or something like i
think he had maybe just retired and
started to find some stuff or maybe he
was at his pre-tattoo mike or yeah
pre-tattoo we're talking bad
[ __ ] mike uh and then his wife
who uh is super famous i didn't know uh
she's like in fresh prince she's in of
other stuff too she literally interrupts
robin gibbons maybe is that her maybe
it's one of will smith's ladies in the
show in the show the one that he
assaulted yeah but she comes
interrupts the interview live like 22.
yeah why are you doing that dude nobody
happened right didn't he like if you can
bite a man's ear off he raped somebody i
think yeah i believe you might punch
your wife yeah but also though robin
gibbons is like notorious for like
ruining mike tyson i don't know what the
narrative is that's because of this i
think yeah she literally interview
interrupts the interview it's in his
house on the couch she just sits down
and starts like talking to barbara
walters and kind of and it's kind of
like awkward at first so she didn't
learn a lesson
i'm just kidding she's obviously both
dude that's what makes me think oh bro
she just starts telling the story about
how he beats her and stuff and he's kind
of sitting there like
he doesn't know oh my god wait so right
in front of barbara wall on the camera
the camera's rolling mike tyson's like
yeah when i was a kid i like peanut
butter and then she just [ __ ]
just comes in and says actual
i like peanut butter
that's so crazy she used that as an
opportunity to finally come out and be
like yo protect my ass this guy's
[ __ ] nuts yeah because there's twenty
twenty castles he was [ __ ] nuts
though to be honest and he admits it now
kind of you know what the story you know
what the story is too i think there was
a very famous story i'm pretty sure it's
rob mcgiverns where mike tyson comes
home
and she is having sex with brad pitt
that's the story
maybe she deserved it there
this is like thelma louise brad pitt
because i think he was in that did mike
tyson beat the living [ __ ] out of you i
think how is brad pitt [ __ ] up brad pays
brad pitt alive you know why because he
knew he was gonna be a great actor he's
like that's when he went fight club mode
he's like i gotta get jack bro mike
tyson's coming do that i'm gonna let you
go cause 12 monkeys is really ground
breaking that movie
[Applause]
damn dude well i mean you know we all
know old mike but you know this says
that mike tyson said he actually used to
punch people who asked him for
autographs
see dude all these stories that's a hell
of a no bro that's a [ __ ] stern
that's one of the craziest quotes and
you don't think he's [ __ ] beating up
girls too at the same time come on man
he was different back i'mma [ __ ] you til
you love me it's one of his great quotes
dude
like i was nuts bro maggot that's what
he says dude how's it going i'm a [ __ ]
you yeah that was a good one
i heard one of his interviews where he's
talking about like you know when he
trained 12 weeks to like literally
murder someone and then when you knocked
him out in the first 40 seconds he goes
you don't have enough blood yet that's
why and the gas station when someone
comes to talk to him beats the [ __ ] out
of him he's still in that [ __ ] raging
mountain
i [ __ ] kill them in 40 seconds i need
more war
dude but that's that's real though dude
that's really real that's like he hasn't
really came yeah you know what i mean
like his yeah blue balls yeah he's got
blue balls but for violence they say
that about actors too who go like method
and [ __ ] like you can't snap out of it
as easily because you're just there what
about daniel day lewis is he like the
ultimate [ __ ] method actor yeah he
became an actual like shoemaker did he
become a boxer he became an actual lady
there's him there's also like heath
ledger and [ __ ] yeah yeah that's true
that's kind of ultimate when you when
you go all the way and you can't come
back that's a little ultimate knight's
tale dude
but we all it says you know we all know
i'm right now
she just did not lay on a horse i was
like dude i love nightstall you guys
like nightstand i do i do love nights to
be honest it was fun as [ __ ] uh but we
know iron mike was uh known for having a
violent streak beyond his baddest man on
the planet and he spent
time in prison for rape
famously bit off evander holyfield's ear
but the 53 year old now feels awful
about his behavior and says that he
lashed out at his adoring fans because
he was unhappy
it obviously makes sense every time it
talks about his past seat he could just
cry yeah i think he feels so bad dude he
was [ __ ] up he just balls just starts
bombing feels so bad about
uh his past you know like his animal
deal like there's obviously the tigers
and stuff that like movies make fun of
but like uh he loves pigeons yeah oh he
raised pigeons one of my favorite
pictures is him [ __ ] painting a
pigeon i thought that was photoshopped
no no he raised pigeons as like a
teenager when he was hopping like foster
homes and then
he would just go on the roof was he into
pigeon racing i don't know but i like
fed them and then started like raise
them on the roof and then maybe they
sent messages yeah i'm gonna win this
one all right
do you know where do you know what he
credits his uh life turnaround to
ayahuasca
marijuana smoking cannabis yeah really
for sure dude every time you probably
mellowed him out he's like yeah why i
have to medicate
always like bart said right there gonna
cry have you guys seen his podcast yeah
dude isn't he always high he's like some
episodes like i just i watch along with
habib because i'm a big hobby fan but
the whole time he's just non-existent
like he's just on the couch like he's
just there he's a placeholder yeah he
got so big that he was like
you could even open his eyes dude
he said after i retired i started
smoking what a mistake that was i should
have smoked my whole career oh so he was
sober i should have smoked when i was
fighting because it put me in a
different state of mind i'm very relaxed
and the more relaxed you are the better
fighter you are at least in my case
that's true but that energy was so
entertaining though but back then though
i feel like old school fighters you kind
of needed that mentality it was like you
can't have sex you can't [ __ ] do
anything you wouldn't have been the same
dude you wouldn't know especially back
then yeah nah dude yeah he would have
just been winning clean and not doing
things like rape yeah potentially but i
feel like but at the same time though
for an athlete like that in this type of
sport in that like
day and era
i don't want to say you kind of ha
obviously the rape stuff is up like
that's crazy but that mindset of having
to be
a killer all the time and going out
there and smash like it's hard to turn
that [ __ ] off and that's why you don't
see very many good fighters that yeah
like especially nowadays like back then
it's a totally different time any sport
though right like the kobe mentality the
mamba mentality the jordan stuff like
some guys need that well how many how
many
how many of those guys bounce back in
general celebrities in general when you
have that kind of a record when you like
are [ __ ] up fans raping people sexual
misconduct and like still are adorable i
think that's why he's so lovable now
he's one of the few that's like that
he's cartooned really went into the deep
end and kind of like found a new voice
and he's like you know mellowed back out
and he's found like success who who else
has come back after such dennis rodman
true i mean even kobe i don't know if
people love the kobe state i love
robin no but kobe didn't [ __ ] up like he
had a rape
that's true no but i'm saying is that
right
sexual assault whatever you want to call
it well he didn't go to jail he didn't
you know yeah but that's who knows why
but it's different from tyson true so
tyson really [ __ ] up like he was on
you know but also maybe because we
expect more out of kobe because he's
like there yeah when you look at mike
tyson he's not all there i got someone
who'd beat tyson yeah oj
oh you see that fool on twitter hey man
it's not okay you're playing golf today
welcome twitter you just [ __ ] know
the goal but i also don't know if people
love them no
no
no there's some juices people do love
them the juice is loose
they're so juicy but tyson be like an ip
man four types of you know what i'm
saying i think he's out of careers he's
starting in a [ __ ] bollywood movie no
way yeah dude he was in like the
hangover like true i think uh people
people separate tyson from his bad
better because oj even under the funny
golf stuff there's always like uh what
are you doing with them gloves on
always funny comments um
and tyson like i said you guys didn't
even hear that 2020 interview like some
of that got hushed for some reason yeah
they did a good job i mean his pr people
did a good job right yeah they did
that's how that works but yeah it's
fascinating because we do see mike tyson
as almost a cartoon character a lot of
the times like the simpsons one you can
disassociate yeah you really can't just
because i i've seen homer simpson
strangle bart and like i remember my mom
was so offended by that when i was a kid
but then like as an adult like i'm i i
just disassociate all that stuff from a
cartoon so it's almost like that with
mike tyson and he does have a cartoon so
it's like a deeper conversation like
cancel culture we don't have to dig into
but like like chris brown yeah full i
mean he beat a famous person he came
he beat up another girl yeah he just got
popped again again i don't know anything
happened after that but there he was
like oh yeah somebody had matthew he
released a new song recently
though right yeah that's top three
everyone can't resist smacking people
dude bro you beat up rihanna dude that's
what i'm saying like you beat the most
famous queen [ __ ] too yeah bro fenty you
can't be [ __ ] touching rihanna like
that you know what i mean i think
someone uh some of it has to do with how
many times you jack up two because then
like what about bones jones everyone's
like wanting to forgive his ass and then
it's like the next one he hasn't dumped
any redeemable stuff so even with chris
brown he beats up a chick but he has a
really nice love song
okay cool like john jones you got to
fight him john jones didn't have any
fundraisers car washes [ __ ] balloon
animals nothing it's just he's a pretty
scummy though so if you slap a woman and
you build an elephant out of balloons
you're cool whatever the people vote for
people vote for chris brown i think it
depends on the audience right because
are we listening to chris brown like is
it a male dominated audience it's
probably female you know what i mean
but i definitely stopped listening to
chris brown a lot i gotta admit that
because i started listening to r kelly
even more no way
some of the i was about to bring him up
because there's layers to this i've
always listened to him as a joke though
that's the difference i never listened
to him in the beginning it was a joke no
dude that [ __ ] was i believe i could
find a hilarious song the passport song
questionable but it it's catchy dude
can't stop remix that's my favorite i
think about it in my head pretty often
let me get your passport do you have
your shots do you want to come to
america how about this how about this
name the name one chick who [ __ ] up
the bounce bag
who [ __ ] up remember everybody got mad
at janet jackson the booby yeah people
got mad at her is that the most out of
chick
that's what i'm saying like maybe one
chick who raped somebody bounce back
with a career or a chick that punched a
fan in the face yeah i don't know yeah
that's true i can't think of one i don't
know if chicks [ __ ] up as hard as guys
know where it is but i think it's a time
thing chicks need to be leading this
country
hey way to get laid bro
i'll tell you just gotta get [ __ ] bro
hell yeah man
they love that [ __ ]
future's female dude
hey come suck my dick at home
[Music]
you